[Musik]
ich habe 40 jahre gegen mich selber ein
kampf tranken am serbischen kriegsopfer
täter uns auf sie es ist ganz wenigen
sich heute wiedergefunden und darum ist
es mir persönlich als großes bedürfnis
sie im land in großer not dienen und dem
frieden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
claudia ist die erste transsexuelle in
der schweizer armee versucht eine frau
die 40 jahre lang einem männerkörper
lebte verheiratet war und vater einer
tochter ist ausgerechnet in dieser
männerwelt davon handelt dieser film
das swiss chalet in truppen lage prizren
im kosovo ist für sechs monate der
lebensmittelpunkt von claudia
sie bekocht die schweizer soldaten sowie
deren deutsche und österreichische
kameraden die hier ihren
friedensfördernden einsatz leisten weil
er mache das wirklich keine rolle ob das
was man oder das traurig militärischen
organisation das ist nicht mein licht
biblis wo man die fälle hätten und wird
auch die disziplin lernen und wochen
viele riesch rang hier war und
jedenfalls transsexuelle sind in der
schweizer armee nicht vorgesehen
als claudia noch andreas und ein mann
war hatte sie es bis zum kurier gebracht
doch das nützte ihr wenig als sie sich
nach der geschlechtsanpassung zum dienst
meldete transsexuelle sein
dienstuntauglich dieses zuerst die
abgabe gebraucht hat
da ist besonders stuntfrau und rechtlich
vor dem gesetz als frau existieren und
die medizinische maßnahmen getroffen
worden sind natürlich geschieht damit am
umgang
das heißt die skaven jährigen kundin
diskriminierung ist sehr sehr groß wo
das ist also ich persönlich sehr
getroffen sie hat mich das eigentlich
vielleicht vorurteil voreiligkeit das
jetzt will man einfach nicht kennt aber
ich bin auch gleichzeitig mehr bewusst
dass es natürlich manchmal muss man gar
und graf und mitmachen bewiesen dass wir
uns noch mal als ein finale angriff dass
die schweizer armee länger braucht um
sich zu einem entscheid durchzuringen
hat seinen grund bisher sah die
militärische krankheitslehre bei
transsexualität zwingend eine dienst
untauglichkeit vor
claudia hat erreicht dass die armee sie
für die stelle als koch rekrutiert juli
pause im system
claudia geht offen direkt auf die
menschen zu aus ihrer transsexualität
macht sie kein geheimnis die ihre
arbeitskollegen ist die ganz und gar
frau und der moment ist vermerkt dass
klassische frau wo sie sich als frau
führt und für mich ist das thema mit dem
genau mit einmal nannte
[Musik]
am nachmittag ist es zeit für den
lebensmitteleinkauf in breese die
einzige gelegenheit für claudia dass
truppen lage zu verlassen und in der
stadt mit einheimischen in kontakt zu
kommen
[Musik]
ein
auf dem örtlichen markt ist claudia eine
gern gesehene kunden
sie kauft für die truppe in großen
mengen früchte und gemüse ein
[Musik]
claudia und ihr begleiter tragen
außerhalb des truppen lage cele waffe
stets auf sich so will es das reglement
als vorher trug sie früher eine pistole
heute schleppt sie als kochen gewehr mit
sicherung
[Musik]
als große blonde frau mit gewehr im
rücken gibt claudia im supermarkt ein
spezielles bild ab abendessen ist sich
charley ihren deutschen gästen serviert
claudia währschafte kostet die deutschen
soldaten genießen claudias
gastfreundschaft dass sie nicht immer
als frau gelebt hat löst bei ihnen
erstaunen aus war doch sehr groß habe
ich nicht mitgerechnet muss ehrlich
sagen weil das ist mir auch überhaupt
nicht aufgefallen
ganz klar also für mich kam die ganze
mal wieder vorüber also überhaupt nicht
hat es heute auch erfahren erst dass sie
sich sozialen entschieden hat um
operieren lassen hat stört mich hat nur
gewundert weil sie ja gar nicht mal so
unattraktiv aussieht aber ich hatte dann
sie mal gefragt wie es denn aussieht mit
heiraten und kinderkriegen usw
und da wir uns da ich das noch nicht
wusste wie ich sie natürlich aus und
sagte mehr nähe und doch nicht und
kinder nie auch nicht wusste ich das
natürlich noch gar nicht jetzt verstehe
ich ihre antwort na klar
ganz klar das funktioniert so nicht
zweimal während ihres kosovo einsatzes
die claudia in die ferien zurück in die
schweiz
was nachhaltig kosovo sein denn ist das
land erkennen aber noch schöneres dass
sie habe er gespürt dass es auch in der
militärischen umfeld für betroffene ganz
menschen wie mich eigentlich problemlos
möglich ist 16 jahre und von der gruppe
insbesondere akzeptiert
die armee ist bei claudias arbeit sehr
zufrieden sie hat ja eine befristete
kader stelle als leiterin des
verpflegung centers bei der swiss sind
in stans angeboten
[Musik]
heute steht für claudia ein treffen mit
weggefährten auf dem programm
sie besucht die transgender tagung in
bern 16 unterricht bewusstmachen
mitwählen hörte dass eigentlich die
revanche plastisch und vielleicht eine
menschen dürfen mit rat und tat zur
seite gestellt der sich etliches großes
alle informiert an der tagung trifft
claudia menschen die sich wie sie selber
nicht mit dem eigenen körper geschlecht
identifizieren können
es geht um den kampf gegen
diskriminierung aber auch um die
auswirkungen verschiedener
operationsmethoden zur
geschlechtsanpassung jürgen scharf
operiert seit 26 jahren männer zu frauen
und umgekehrt
[Musik]
der münchner chirurg hat auch bei
claudia die geschlechts an passenden
eingriffe durchgeführt
er ist überzeugt dass sie jetzt bei sich
selbst angekommen ist
es gibt so ein paar kleinigkeiten wo man
eine gewisse selbstbewusstsein und
durchsetzungskraft vorhanden ist wie man
es ansonsten nur bei männern oft aber
das ist ja nicht immer das gleiche und
gott sei dank gibt es ja auch viele
selbstbewusste frauen deswegen sie wirkt
für mich als absolute frau den gruß muss
ich ihnen noch ausrichten
von dem von meinem ersten mal papa
ratifizierten gute arbeit gemacht
ja ich habe nur ein bereich operiert
wurde
schwierig ist darüber nun hier aller
öffentlichkeit zu berichten
aber offensichtlich hat das alles gut
funktioniert bei der logopädin isabel
schaller hat claudia gelernt in einer
weiblichen tun lage zu sprechen
genau vor wie das nicht wieder die
stimme muss sondern es ist ja auch
identität fragte kommt sie stimmen dass
es im musste schlussendlich zu mir
sauber aus zum beispiel traumfrau passen
in gewissen lebenssituationen nutzt
claudia den vorteil dass sie mit einer
weiblichen und einer männlichen stimme
sprechen kann
es gibt natürlich den moment wenn ich an
garagen kann eine piste wo das auto
rückblende kurz vor weihnachten 2011
eröffnete claudia ihrer familie sowie
ihre damaligen lebenspartner in esther
dass sie von nun an als frau leben
wollen die überraschung bei den eltern
war groß
esther und claudia blieben vorerst
zusammen
im oktober 2012 verkaufte claudia das
hotel schwefel bergbad und zog nach bern
[Musik]
heute ist für claudia ein besonderer tag
zum ersten mal nach dem verkauf ihres
hotels fährt sie wieder ins schwefel
bergbad europa gelten für die
geschlechter passen operationen können
das machen ja also das ist zweifelsohne
ist für mich das einen ganzen
wesentlichen check sie wenn ich kann ihm
keiner hatte der letzte ist nicht machen
juni mit dem hotel gegangen weil die
belastung formalistische betrieb hätte
ich mich nicht anders
die operation war
[Musik]
wegen verzögerungen mit dem umbau ist
das hotel seit über zwei jahren
geschlossen
[Musik]
besitzer von einem hotel schlange
jahresmotto das hotel geführt hat das
gefühl sich crysis hätte mal wüste
familie gehört es ist gefühl aber auf wo
müsste okay der weg weitergegangen für
mich persönlich ist nötig sie dass sie
das mini werk august gute tricks sie
sicher bis 39 die studienzeit
hundertprozentig richtig
okay der heimischen gemüses doppel aber
für dörfer froh sie nicht das ziel ist
es ist die hölle ist schlimmste was mir
passiert ist es ist unbeschreiblich war
immer wie die drucke die rollen muss
gesellschaftsspiele mit dem hotel sind
viele erinnerungen an claudias ehemalige
lebenspartnerin esther verbunden
vor einigen monaten haben sich die wege
der beiden getrennt
ich habe jetzt training vor es der regen
wurde priester für freude über die ganze
fläche schwierige frage ich glaube es
ist verständlich dass das die frau
gestanden ist und auch wirklich sagen
zwar immer nicht zweigleisig fahren
ich bin nicht schwul aber ich stehe
trotzdem muss man doch sehr 12 stand dem
comic network time god for fun verlag so
immer noch große dankbarkeit dass das
möglich ist die beziehung auf ein
anderes führe ich hab ja ja sich mac
copy somit ob es ist nur eine seite
gestürzt unterstützt mit sie ja es ist
eine unendliche dankbarkeit das ist ein
übliches dank hat er münchen ich heute
noch extrem gern als ist nicht
lebensfähig sie in der beziehung
zwischen mensch weil ich alles wird gut
für im kanton bern hat claudia die
änderung ihres personen standes von
männlich weiblich gerichtlich erstritten
nun haben sie die aargauer zivilstand
beamten zu einem vortrag eingeladen
der gang in ein amtsgebäude hat für
claudia mittlerweile seinen schrecken
verloren
die aargauer standesbeamten wollen sich
ein bild machen von den hürden der
transsexuellen in zivil stands
rechtlichen fragen
drinnen im saal übernimmt claudia sofort
das zepter
[Musik]
große defizite allemal luft steht das
publikum in frauen und männer auf und
presst je eine person in der anderen
geschlechter gruppe macht sich wie neu
geboren
die versuche dieses gap ich jetzt jahr
lang probiert aber das ist mir sagen sie
es ist streng ich sie es hat einfach
eine welle funktionieren
claudius referat setzt bei den aargauer
gemeinde beamten einiges in bewegung
die österreicher sehr beeindruckt wie
sie über das über die geschichte
wenn ich vier monate anschaut dann würde
ich sehe hier werden wenn die personen
in kontakt kam
zur person aber wenn ihr der kontakt hat
und wie sich ganz an personen zu offenen
und einer gewissen verständnis für die
situation
[Musik]
seit claudia als frau lebt hat sie das
malen für sich entdeckt
sie ist in gedanken oft bei ihrer heute
14 jährigen tochter die bei ihrer mutter
in deutschland lebt und sie hat das
relativ rasch begriff ich glaube wenn
man geld ältere denkmal und frau in
erster linie sondern vielleicht als mami
und papi oder im falle zu erhalten
zwei ältere teil wobei heftig bio-rad
biologisch der vater das weiß ich habe
doch ich betrachte mich als elternteil
oder mini tochter mich nicht marina und
relativ wenig kontakt mit jährigen ab
die in deutschland wird es für euch was
du dir doch sie das ist nicht ganz
einfach aber ich verstehe natürlich auch
situation dass mögliche tochter nicht
gerade in der schule wo mehrere hundert
schüler sind out claudia hofft dass sie
den kontakt zu ihrer tochter zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt intensiver pflegen
kann
[Musik]
regelmäßig wird claudia mit freunden auf
den thunersee zu tauchen
das tauchen ist claudias große
leidenschaft
sie mag es schwerelosen tiefen wasser zu
schweben
[Musik]
in claudias leben hat sich vieles zum
guten entwickelt ihre freunde
akzeptieren sie voll und ganz als frau
nur eines fehlt ihr noch
die große liebe
mehrere male hat claudia erlebt dass
sich männer von ihr abwenden sobald sie
von ihrer vergangenheit erfahren
ich warte auf den puck vor langfristig
den multimedia einsatz warten
was braucht der trägerschaft oder mit
klappert ich glaube dass großes herz
viel verständnis und vor allem viel
courage wenn wirklich ein
er braucht natürlich ist das gleich was
claudia ist wo der ursprung foto claudia
sind mir ist wichtig wo man herkommt
zusammen
das ist mir wichtig wie zuversichtlich
sie koste die große liebe findet ich
weiß es nicht mehr gesehen und ich
glaube mich überrascht es gibt sichere
der moment wo man für das jemals wieder
über aber ich denke mit lori haben
wieder bewiesen dass man muss noch
einmal um kritisch mit dem ruf stehen
wieder laufen
[Musik]